-Guys, as you know, every week,
we like to bring you some
uplifting, creative videos,
whether they come from
quarantine
or just stuff
around the country.
So it's time for
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."
-♪ What are you doing
on Wednesday? ♪
♪ What are you
doing on Wednesday? ♪
-First up, this French bulldog
makes some pretty strange sounds
when he gets excited.
Take a look.
[ Dog screaming ]
-Oh, yeah? No. No.
[ Screaming continues ]
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, sir, there's something
wrong with your baby.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, it seems like this kid
has been overhearing
a lot of work calls
in quarantine,
because this is what he does
when his parents' phone rings.
[ Cellphone ringing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Claps hands ]
[ Laughter continues ]
♪♪
He's so cute.
[ Laughs ]
"When I was your age, we used to
dance to the dial-up tone.
Here comes the thunder."
[ Punch lands! ]
"You broke my other arm."
Next up, this woman's husband
wanted her to cut back
on her spending in quarantine.
And she found a pretty great way
to get him back.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Tiny egg! Tiny egg!
And finally, this guy's
social-distance birthday party
got ruined by a confetti cannon.
Take a look.
-Yes.
-[Bleep] Ah!
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
There you go, everybody.
That is "What Are You Doing
Wednesdays."